hi there steve here today i want to
share with you my experience on duolingo
i had some difficulties and perhaps some
of you who are more experienced with
duolingo can help me out
once again if you enjoy these
videos please subscribe
i apologize for the sound on the last uh
video i experimented with a new
microphone
it didn't work out uh because uh prior
to that i had been using a lapel mic
and there were complaints that there was
a bit clipped so
today i'm just using the microphone the
built-in microphone
in the iphone itself we'll see if that
works out better now duolingo
my experience with duolingo um
i decided to use it for greek because
that's the language that i started
studying a couple of weeks ago
and so here is what i found and and i'd
be interested in in re i jotted down
some notes
first of all going into duolingo i found
that i sort of had to choose between
being a beginner
or testing myself to see what my level
was
so since i'm essentially a beginner i
went to beginner and i found that the
beginner
uh
lessons or whatever is just too boring
too slow they test you on the names of
letters
uh and on a few very simple words so i
said you know i'm going to be there
forever i'm already well past that
because i've been doing
uh who is she one of our
that's a 26 chapter lesson at link i've
i started doing a bit of living language
by the way i i bought the uh the app for
living language which i have on my ipad
which is much better than the book it's
essentially the same content but you
have text-to-speech it's easier to
navigate it's far superior and less
expensive than the book had i known i
wouldn't have bought the book but that's
another issue so i've already had some
exposure to greek so i i just found that
this this was just so slow
in the beginner area and there's a bunch
of stuff that's locked so you they force
you and i don't like this i i like
freedom if i buy a book i don't like the
idea that
you know
only the first five pages are visible to
me and until i have tested on those five
pages all the remaining pages are locked
i like to flip through and come back
so i didn't like that all right
um
so then i said well i'll test myself to
maybe find a level for myself so i go in
to start taking their text test
um
and the the uh
of course i'm going to get most of them
wrong
but
i think the idea of of testing is that
somehow you're going to learn these
basics and when you have
mastered these basics then you move
forward that's a principle that i'm very
much opposed to i believe in language
learning we learn and forget the basics
and then we move on to some other stuff
that's interesting and challenging and
then we go back to the basics again it's
not like we're building these solid
you know
putting bricks in place to a wall that
we're building it's constantly sort of
in flux so i didn't appreciate that and
a lot of the testing even the testing
was a lot of letters like alpha omegran
you know and so then what you're being
tested on is either
these letters or
um the first word that they test you on
to determine your level is the flower
well i don't think flower is
to me all that important a word when i
start in to a language
and now and the other thing too is they
ask you to type in greek and i had been
resisting typing in greek so one of the
benefits of getting into duolingo is
that i have to type in greek so i went
and found a greek
keyboard for my mac and i started typing
in greek and as with so many things in
language learning that we think er you
know
it
could be a big obstacle in fact typing
in greek is very easy it's largely
phonetic as i would type in english and
there's a few other letters that i have
to look for on the keyboard viewer in my
mac so that was a good thing
so and then uh but some of the questions
even in this testing you know
they test you for
you know what is this letter and
z zed or however they say it zita in
greek zeta they spell z-e-e-t-a
so i thought this was some other word
zeita or something because zita i would
have written z-i-t-a
no big deal but it's just
uh very much
i don't know then the next word they
test you on or phrase is the flower and
the megaphone so the first word is the
flower the second word is the flower and
the megaphone
and then the word bad shows up three
times like i don't know what sort of
frequency they're using or why they
select these words then came the word
for
pineapple ananas
ananas pineapple then they had fee
written
p-h-e-e and i had to write that in greek
i had to figure out that it was actually
feed whatever a alpha so a lot of
letters and stuff
but a lot of the book genuine vocabulary
of course
uh i was getting wrong so
i failed so that's fine that's some
messaging about run out of hearts or
something so then i went back and i saw
that there was another i didn't want to
go back to beginner
but there was a place where i could
do a test again
and here i could choose
i think it wasn't clear to me but they
had
various groups phrases food animals
clothing
pos which i presume is possessive
questions
verb
verbs color
well
again
as a beginner in a learning a language
food
animals clothing colors i have zero
interest in any of those
other than to the extent that they
appear in some meaningful context
uh so then it's a test out of seven
skills so i go in there i'm gonna test
myself again the first word that shows
up that i have to write
in i think i had to translate from
greek into english was the hamburger
the second one was
and i had to write this in
no sorry i had to go from english to
greek the hamburger this is followed by
the pizza does not have
lemon
uh the third one was it is his dog
well of course i failed them all so go
back to home out of hearts and i start
up again
another interesting thing is i i would
get like some of the letters i would get
them wrong because that eventually i
just wanted to get through the thing so
i would type anything they had something
there i just hit a greek letter
and very often on something that was
obviously wrong i would be given correct
or almost correct so
i mean
that i'm just telling you what my
experience was with duolingo i can't
i want to get to something interesting
meaningful
uh i was frustrated like normally if i
hadn't decided that i was going to um
try to write a review of duolingo and i
hadn't got far enough into it to really
write a review
but i'm out of there because
i want to see some some context some
i want to have more freedom i don't want
to be tested at every step by the way so
that has been my
somewhat frustrating initial exposure to
duolingo
probably i should stick with it longer
but i'm not that motivated to do so
other than for the purpose of um of
writing a review so if some of you can
give me some advice that would encourage
me to go further i'll go further in the
duolingo and maybe enjoy it more
maybe write a more
meaningful review but that's really all
i have to say on duolingo at this point
bye for now
hi there just
an afterthought okay uh
later this is now the evening i did the
uh video
this morning and i've been thinking
during the day we went shopping for food
and i've been thinking about what i said
about duolingo and there were a number
of thoughts running about in my head
that i thought i would share with you
sort of at the end of this video
there are lots of different kinds of
people
um you know there's much talk about uh
you know we need to be more
entrepreneurial that
you know the republicans for example in
the us are saying if we
lower taxes then the actual
entrepreneurial spirit will come forward
and stuff not everybody is an
entrepreneur not everyone is a motivated
independent language learner so
uh not everyone approaches language
learning the way i do uh
very possibly probably because duolingo
is very popular
of course it's free which is a big
advantage to some people although to me
um
you know my time is more valuable than
my money
uh but for many people the fact that
that it's free is a major uh incentive
but it's it's beyond that it's i think
many people like to get that
regular pat on the back uh they might
like to be prodded uh you know and uh so
is this an orange or is it a an apple
and they say orange
and that's good and they move forward
and and even you know this issue like i
personally don't like to get a whole
list of colors or lists of parts of the
body or
types of clothing to try to learn
because my experience tells me that it's
very difficult to learn these things
i can learn one color or one object of
clothing
in a particular story or context and if
i see it again and again and again
eventually it'll stick if i try to learn
you know ten different items of clothing
or ten parts of the body i just find it
extremely difficult to do
but i can see where for some people
being tested on their ability to
remember from a list of 10
you know whatever it might be items of
clothing or other things that they have
learned and then they get tested on it
right away that that could be very
motivating and therefore keep them on
task and in language learning of course
the most important thing is to keep
people on task so to the extent that
duolingo is able to
keep people motivated to stay with
learning the language then it is a good
system so i just wanted to make the
point that you know first of all people
ask me here on youtube you know what do
you think of this what do you think of
that what do you think of asi mill what
do you think of duolingo what do you
think of something else so i thought i
would have a look at duolingo
plus i was starting into greek so for
example i bought living language and i
thought duolingo can help me i certainly
want to use duolingo for greek so and
then i thought i'll look into it see if
it helps me and then i'll do a review so
that's why i got into this uh business
of doing a review but i don't want to
imply that it's not good for
anybody it's probably good for a large
number of people but
personally i think it's more valuable
to
you know i get back to stephen krashen
and compelling content and what i see is
missing in duolingo is compelling
content interesting content so that
very soon uh i'm motivated to learn
about greece through greek right now i'm
still doing
relatively simple stories but it's still
a story it's a context and i'm i'm
working my way through reading uh you
know and looking things up and hearing
text-to-speech word and then phrase and
then sentence and
and yet when i listen i don't understand
it and i'm but i know from experience
that in a month or two i will understand
and so i'm dealing with meaningful
context and i don't see that in duolingo
therefore for me as a learner duolingo
probably won't work
but for many other people this might be
the first chance that they have a sense
of success and achievement and
motivation in learning a language so to
that extent um you know it may not be
for me i'm going to try it again but it
may be perfectly valid for a lot of
people so i just thought i'd add that in
so i didn't come across too negative on
duolingo so thank you for listening let
me have your views
[Music]
you